bienvenue à tous pour ce tout nouveau
numéro de Paris sa clé TV le magazine
qui vous tient informé de toute
l'actualité de votre territoire
aujourd'hui on vous présente le cluster
TIC Paris sa clé et l'un des pôles
français et européens en matière de
technologie de l'information et de la
communication illustration avec une
toute nouvelle appli spread ces
concepteurs sont passés par incbe
alliance nous y sommes justement nous
allons vous y emmener et vous allez
comprendre le rôle que tient cette
structure sur votre territoire à suivre
aussi le décryptage d'Isabelle Ramad
elle nous dira tout sur l'op source à ne
pas confondre avec les licences libres
nous l'avons rencontré enfin vous
découvrirez le réseau plateau un réseau
qui permet au chef d'entreprise de
confronter leurs idées à un point de vue
extérieur enfin notre agenda toutes les
informations de Paris sa clé en bref et
en image ce sera à la fin de cette
édition aujourd'hui on s'intéresse donc
au ticle la technologie de l'information
et de la communication c'est l'un des
secteurs phar du cluster Paris saclé
37000 employés plus de 400 entreprises
sur le territoire et chaque jour de
nouvelles initiatives comme
l'application spread il s'agit d'une
carte de visite numérique augmentée
regardez le cluster TIC c'est un
formidable regroupement d'industriels et
aussi de groupes de recherche publique
comme le CNRS l'ineria le CA dans une
zone assez assez restreinte même si on
parle du plateau de sa clé qui fait
qu'il y a énormément d'échanges entre
ces acteurs donc ça crée une
dynamique pour pour innover tout
simplement moi personnellement je
connais bien ce cluster parce que j'ai
fait ma thèse entre l'Université Paris
Sud et
Supelec une thèse en théorie des jeux
pour les télécommunications et c'est via
Supelec que j'ai pu me lancer dans
l'entrepreneuriat et c'est Supelec qui
m'a fait embrayer dans un incubateur là
on est aujourd'hui incbe alliance qui
est un incubateur public et qui permet
aux personnes comme moi issues de la
recherche publique de se lancer dans les
meilleures conditions dans l'aventure
entrepreneuriale aujourd'hui j'ai en
plus profité du cluster pour mon
activité entrepreneuriale je profite
aussi d'une aide à l'innovation un
accélérateur qui s'appelle sanple qui
permet de financer le développement des
startup nous ce qu'on fait c'est une
application qui s'appelle spread donc
c'est une application mobile sur iPhone
et sur android qui permet de partager
simplement des contenus numériques qu'on
a tout le temps avec soi aux personnes
qu'on rencontre par exemple si ça tombe
bien on on est un cube alliance si je
veux donner ce contenu à mon associé qui
est dans la salle d'à côté je vois tout
suite son profil je peux cliquer sur son
image et tout de suite il va recevoir le
contenu uniquement parce qu'on est en
proximité physique on n pas besoin
d'avoir d'abord une adresse email ou un
numéro de téléphone pour partager je
peux même aller plus loin en partageant
directement un contenu à un lieu et là
je peux partager à toutes les personnes
qui sont dans notre bureau donc on rend
le partage de compen numérique aussi
simple qu'avoir une
conversation comme le cluster est assez
dense effectivement on a l'occasion de
se se retrouver avec les autres acteurs
du plateau à mainreprise et notamment
bah demain je crois que je peux le dire
on va rencontrer Alcatel Lucent pour
voir si on pourrait travailler avec eux
et avec leur cité l'innovation euh on
est aussi on travaille aussi avec le
proto de 104 pour équiper le lieu pour
les événements ainsi que le pôle
entrepreneurial de l'École polytechnique
donc effectivement c'est assez simple et
dynamique de créer des liens avec les
les acteurs du
PI comme beaucoup de chercheurs François
Merot a bénéficié de l'expertise
d'uncube alliance nous nous trouvons
justement dans cette structure qui met
en contact les scientifiques les
financiers et les entrepreneurs Philippe
Morau le directeur de l'Incubateur
Technologique du Campus Paris sac Île de
France nous en dit
plus
incubAlliance c'est l'Incubateur
Technologique mutualisé du Campus Paris
saclé c'est en terme de de volume de
projet et en terme d'anciens projets
transformés en société en entreprise le
premier incubateur technologique de
France il a déjà une quinzaine d'années
d'existence et globalement plus de 260
projets sont passés par l'incubateur et
ils ont donné lieu à environ 160
entreprises qui sont vivantes et actives
dans notre écosystème et au-delà en
France et à
l'étranger notre métier consiste donc à
accompagner les projets avant la
création des start-ups jusqu'à leur
démarrage commercial après que bien sûr
la société a été créée après que le
business model la stratégie de la
start-up a été travaillé et retravaillé
avec nous pendant de longues séances de
travail après que l'équipe a été
renforcée après que le produit a été
commercialisé bref toutes ces activités
concernent l'incubation et nous y
contribuons nous aidons l'entrepreneur à
faire en sorte qu'il sorte par le E vers
une trajectoire prometteuse à la sortie
de de
l'incubateur nous sommes un incubateur
généraliste donc nous avons des projets
de start-up qui couvre tous les domaines
technologiques nous avons des projets
qui concernent les sciences de la vie et
les biotèques nous travaillons avec
notre écosystème notamment genénopole
Cancer Campus nous avons beaucoup de
projets qui concernent les technologies
traditionnelles de l'ingénieur notamment
l'optique euh et nous travaillons
notamment avec l'écosystème d'optique
comme auquel appartient optics Valley et
l'IOGS l'école d'optique et nous
travaillons bien sûr sur tous les
projets titic euh incontournable surtout
à Paris
saint-clé incub alliance est est
constitutif du territoire a été la
première plateforme mutualisée du
plateau de saclé les membres d'incbe
alliance sont tous les établissements de
recherche et de développement et
d'enseignement supérieur du plateau de
sa clé dans les Gunes même de
l'entreprise se trouve la recherche et
le développement et notamment ce qu'on
appelle le rapprochement ou l'adossement
des projets au laboratoire de recherche
et développement du plateau de sa
clé et maintenant cette question
qu'est-ce que l'Open Source pas si
facile d'y répondre Isabelle Ramad
professeur agrégé relève le défi elle
nous rappelle ainsi la différence entre
logiciel libre et open source un
éclairage nécessaire tant ces questions
sont importantes ici sur le plateau
Paris saacé mais pas seulement c'est
notre rubrique
décryptage le logiciel libre c'est un
type de logiciel qui se remonte aux
années 80 et qui est défini par quatre
grandes libertés fond fondamental qui
est le droit de d'utiliser des logiciels
donc par apposition à des des logiciels
commerciaux traditionnels qu'il faut
acheter donc on ne peut pas utiliser
librement mais avec également d'autres
libertés qui sont fondamentales par
rapport à la au dynamisme que peut
représenter le logiciel libre c'est la
possibilité d'étudier le code source de
de ces logiciels la possibilité de le
modifier et enfin la possibilité une
fois qu'on a modifié et en général
amélioré un logiciel libre exist an de
rediffuser de façon à faire bénéficier
le plus grand nombre rediffuser les les
versions modifiées de ces
logiciels le terme Open Source est
arrivé un peu un peu après en 98 si ma
mémoire est bonne parce que il y avait
essentiellement une ambigué
malencontreuse dans la langue anglaise
on parlait de Free Software et free
software ça veut à la fois dire logiciel
libre et logiciel gratuit autour des la
fin des années 90 il y a des un certain
nombre d'entrepreneurs américains au
début et puis il y en avait aussi en
France quelques-uns qui se sont dit que
ce ces logiciels libres en fait
représentaient un matériel extrêmement
intéressant pour créer tout un nouvel
écosystème toute une nouvelle dynamique
économique un peu par opposition au
logiciel traditionnel propriétaire dont
on avait à l'époque déjà senti un
certain nombre de limites et donc il est
apparu intéressant et même nécessaire de
de changer la la dénomination donc de
faire en sorte de lever cette ambiguité
entre logiciel gratuit donc qui ne peut
pas donner lieu à la création
d'entreprise création de d'emplois
autour de ces logiciels et au contraire
une appellation nouvelle bon les gens
ont inventé open source de façon à au
contraire légit légitimer toute cette
activité économique qui s'est
considérablement développé depuis la fin
des années 90 puis qu'en france au au
jour d'aujourd'hui on doit compter à peu
près 3 4 milliards d'euros par an de
chiffre d'affaires autour du logiciel
libre et probablement entre 30 et 50000
emplois il y a vraiment un besoin
d'embaucher des spécialistes du logiciel
libre qui sont formés par les
universités les écoles d'ingénieurs dont
certaines sont présentes sur le campus
de Paris
saclé un plateau pour le plateau il
fallait y penser ce programme baptisé
plateau permet d'accompagner pendant 2
ans les PME les petites et moyennes
entreprises leurs dirigeants peuvent
bénéficier du suivi de l'expérience de
grandes entreprises comment ça marche
pour quel résultat élément de réponse
avec M de Paris Davide elle est
animatrice réseau plateau à la Chambre
de commerce et d'industrie de Versailles
nous l'avons
rencontré le réseau plateau a été cré
dans les années 80 en Belgique mais a
démarré dans les Yvelines en 2001 et sur
le territoire de 50 ans en Yveline le
premier réseau plateau a été lancé en
2011 le réseau plateau Paris Saclay est
géré par la Chambre de commerce
Versailles Eveline et la Chambre de
commerce de lessonne et bénéficie du
soutien de partenaires tels que la
communauté d'agglomération de 50 an en
iveline la Communauté d'agglomération du
plateau de sacely la communauté
d'agglomération Europe et son et bien
entendu l'établissement public Paris-
SACM alors le réseau plateau est un
réseau d'entreprisees qui regroupe des
dirigeants de PME et des cadres de
grands groupe l'originalité du réseau
plateau c'est que ce sont les dirigeants
d'entreprise qui choisissent les thèmes
des réunions le format des réunions
ainsi que l'horaire des réunions dans
les groupes de travail plateau les
dirigeants d'entreprise vont échanger
sur les bonnes pratiques dans tout ce
qui est gestion d'entreprise par exemple
recrutement
commercial gestion de la trésorerie et
cetera tout ce qui concerne les
dirigeants de PME au
quotidien je suis président de la SAS
Océanis environnement donc entreprise
spécialisée dans la gestion l'entretien
et la réhabilitation des milieux
aquatiques sur
l'île-de-fance il faut dire que plateau
c'est pour rompre l'isolement du chef
d'entreprise il faut reconnaître et le
dire que en tant que chef d'entreprise
on est investi d'un pouvoir de décision
très large et les décisions que nous
prenons ne sont pas forcément les bonnes
parce que c'est soit on a les moyens et
on va s'entourer de conseils ou
d'experts mais malheureusement ce un
coup voilà les plateau nous permet
d'échanger entre chef
d'entreprise et voilà par TV c'est déjà
terminé onrouve très vite pour nouveau
numé pour tout savoir de l'actualité de
votre
territoire